serbie que reste-t-il
tu manges pas fondées mais comprenez
chine allait enfin ça fait plaisir
c'est à l'envers puisque elle a disparu
comment c'est possible qu'il soit parti
comme ça où il est surveillé pas n'est
ce pas une prison ce qui n'est sûr on
attend des impasses ou alors c'est déjà
arrivé quelques fois mais enfin bon
c'est rare
c'est la première fois en c'est une
vraie passoire le bain peut pas lancer
un avis de recherche est la télé basler
temps avec leur alerte enlèvement qu'on
va faire pareil une première question
est ce que votre mère est majeur du dr
paul on voit tous nous ici mr john jeu
son fils tu as déjà vu ça toi [ __ ] tu
reçu une carte postale de ma grand mère
obtient il faut que tu mènes l'enquêté
suit soit vous voulez vous suicider non
je pense qu'on a quand même le meilleur
spot pour ça ici alors écoutez moi je
veux pas m'immiscer dans votre vie
privée mais moi en tant que
professionnel je suis obligé de vous
prévenir ronge la falaise comme ça
attaque on arrive ici on saute on est
venu pour ça
sauf que en cas de vent retour en
arrière parce qu'on peut nous aider en
fait j'ai su que ma vie ah bah il
faudrait dire à votre visage alors parce
que là on peut pas deviner
jean plus ronde et c'est tout pour moi
campan
notre caractère ta mère
c'est bien le genre à part ça comme ça
à table on l'a